sam nabli bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france on va revenir sur les
accusations qui pèsent sur sur boris
johnson mais avant un point sur la
situation sanitaire hier il a parlé d'un
raz-de-marée face aux variants omicron
vous le constatez aussi la situation
sanitaire est inquiétante au royaume uni
pour le moment la situation n'est pas
inquiétante mais ce qu'on remarque c'est
que ce variant au micro est en train de
se propager à une vitesse extraordinaire
le nombre de cas est en train
d'augmenter à peu près il est en train
de doubler en deux jours donc si cette
propagation exponentielle
va causer énormément de cas pendant
cette période de noël et pourrait faire
que l'admission au niveau de l'oeil
hôpitaux ne va pas plus être fait parce
que le nombre de lits va manquer donc
c'est ça ce qu'on abat peur surtout
qu'avec le micro s'il faut pas oublier
que nous avons des verrues ceci l'abri
de la grippe est un peu là et si
malheureusement ce virus aussi
augmentent donc là ça va être vraiment
un grand problème pour nous notre
système de santé est un tout petit peu
en train de travailler maintenant avec
une petite surcharge comparé à
normalement donc on est en train
d'essayer de faire face pour que cette
situation ne s'aggrave pas alors on dira
que le vario mikron semble être très
contagieux effectivement mais peut-être
moins dangereux que les précédentes
souche du cause il dans ce contexte la
res qu'il est néanmoins nécessaire de se
préparer justement une forte vague
oui exactement donc ce variant il se
propage très rapidement
il paraît que c'est pas grave mais c'est
pas grave dans 90% des cas on va avoir
l'occasion de spécialisé d'aidé des
patients dont les 10 autres pour sont
des cas mais 1 10% deux cent mille cas
où 1 50% de 10000 ça va être la même
chose parce que avec ce très grand
nombre de personnes atteintes
l'hôpital doit pouvoir
accepter les patients qui vont être
fragile les patients qui ont eu un
vaccin qui date de plus de trois mois
donc ce qui fait ces gens là vont devoir
être hospitalisée
donc c'est ça qui nous fait peur alors
devant les députés doivent examiner de
nouvelles mesures de nouvelles
restrictions justement pour faire face à
cette nouvelle vague dans ce contexte la
boris johnson lui est accusé de ne pas
avoir respecté ses propres règles alors
comment réagissent les britanniques
écoutez les britanniques c'est des gens
qui entend de la science et ses de
comply essai de de faire ce qu'on leur
demande etc
il ya certaines personnes qui disent que
on va faire une enquête et l'enquète va
nous dire ce qui sent la responsable et
ses responsables là vont être
bien sûr
mise à l'écart ou rêvant démissionner
ils vont être puni pour ce qu'ils ont
fait mais en fin de compte
johnson lui il nous dit un tout petit
peu ce qu'il faut faire pour que la
nation reste un tout petit peu aller que
reste à l'abri de ce virus n'a donc
aucune question il ne reste crédible
c'est ce que vous nous dites
écouter les légendes les gens disent que
c'est pas bien ce qu'il a fait s'il est
au courant parce qu'il dit qu'il n'est
pas au courant
mais c'est c'est vrai qu'il n'aime pas
ça d'ailleurs le pôle le sondage qu'il a
été fait a montré que les que les lèvres
ils sont en train de perdre de la vence
par rapport aux que les conservatif
plutôt sont en train de perdre de la
vence par rapport aux lèvres mais ils
disent qu'en fin de compte on s'en fout
de ça et on veut on veut aller de
l'avant et on peut avoir les mesures
qu'il faut et discuter les choses les
plus importantes et ne pas rester sur
quelques points là chi chi en revanche
telle nouvelle mesure justement sont sur
la table aujourd'hui
écouter pour le moment on va commencer à
nouveau de travailler à partir de la
maison donc ça va essayer de réduire
le fait que les gens aillent travailler
donc ils vont rester chez eux
et travailler si possible à part 2
deuxièmement il va voir les vacances
scolaires donc ça va arrêter la
scolarisation donc ça vient au même
moment que les vacances scolaires
troisièmement toutes les personnes qui
rentrent à londres sont obligés de faire
un pcr avant d'arriver de s'isoler à
londres de qu'il arrive et de faire un
autre pc à l'antre pour confirmer que
ils n'ont pas le corona ensuite on va
commencer à utiliser le patient ni terre
donc tout ce qui est boîte de nuit tout
ce qui est
manifestation à l'intérieur où les
grandes manifestations à l'extérieur
donc ce sens les ensuite le port du
masque bien sûr partout où c'est
possible ou ça ne dérange pas le premier
ministre qui vise aussi sur le rappel de
la troisième dose avant noël est ce que
c'est possible à ce que les britanniques
prennent rendez vous est ce que ça ne
bouchonne pas finalement pour les prises
de rendez vous
pour le moment on en a fait on a fait
beaucoup de rappel et c'est vrai que
c'est là l'une des plus grandes mesures
qu'on est en train de prendre pour part
pour réduire cette infection on sait que
le troisième rappel si les faits
ça va être
un grand avantage parce que ça diminue
l'infection
donc
le vaccin oms lui-même constitue un
traitement préventif de cette infection
si les personnes regard vaccia moins de
trois mois on est sûre à 75 % qui
n'auront pas de manifestation de
coronavirus dual au micro
merci houssam nabli d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes médecin
infectiologue à l'ombre